-Welcome back to the show
in person.
-Thank you! I know!
-I mean...
-We're back.
-You're back in New York City.
-Here we are.
-This is your hometown.
-This is it.
-How's it feel?
-Feels great.
-It does, right?
-It feels amazing.
-I wanted to ask you because
tonight's a big show for us.
We have -- obviously, you're on.
But I mean, we have, the Olympic
opening ceremonies was tonight
and I heard that you were almost
in an Olympic commercial once.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is that true?
-Yes.
Well, I was in
an Olympic commercial.
-You were?
-I don't think it aired.
Because I might -- I --
[ Laughs ]
Okay, so here's the story.
The story is I went in
to audition
and you know, when you first
start auditioning,
I went in as a dancer
and kind of like whatever.
And they were like,
"Okay, can you dance?"
I danced and then I talked
and I read the copy
and I did the things,
and then they were like,
"By the way" -- I'm walking out
and I'm like, I nailed this.
I killed this.
-I got this.
I was great today.
Today was my day.
-Yes, exactly.
-I'm walking out and I'm like,
"Okay, bye, thank you.
Thank you so much. Thank you."
And I walk out
and the guy says to me,
right before I leave, he goes,
"Hey, by the way,
can you do trampoline?"
And I go, "Yeah."
And I walk out,
thinking nothing of it.
-Sure. Yeah.
-Can I do a trampoline?
Are you kidding me?
-I get there and I do
all the things, I dance, I sing,
and then they bring out this
trampoline and they're like,
"Okay!"
-"Let's see what you got."
-"Do it!"
And I was like...okay.
They're like, "You know, you do
the flips and the things."
And I was like, "Sure,
I'll do the trampoline."
I get up there and I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
That was it.
That's all I had.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cut to c--
Is that all she does?
Did she do the trampoline?
-I did this!
I did this, I jumped,
and I did some of this.
-You posed.
-It was awful.
-That's not doing trampoline.
-And they were like, "You said
you could do trampoline."
And I said, "No, I..."
-I'm sorry.
-I did, but I didn't know
what you meant.
-How's the fam?
-Everybody's good.
-Two teenagers.
-I know.
-Wow, is that wild.
-I know, does anybody else
have teenagers right now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-It's interesting, right?
-It is. It is.
You know, they go from like
being these babies,
and then when they turn
like 11 1/2, 12,
they become like adult people
in a little body.
-I know, I know.
I'm like -- every second,
I love hanging out with my kids
because I just don't want you
to grow up, but I do.
-What they do is
that they need to, like,
distance themselves a little.
You know, it's my life.
I have my own identity.
I am who I am, this is what
I feel about the world.
This is what I think.
And, you know, it's like,
Oh, my God, and I'm like,
"Baby, you want to sit
on my lap?"
[ Both laugh ]
-No, I don't now.
I'm a teenager. Not at all.
-Mom, stop. Stop touching me.
-I'll tell you
who is here tonight --
your mom is here.
-Who also likes me
to still sit on her lap.
-Lupe is here tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Mom.
-Hi, beautiful.
Oh, my god, she is
the prettiest, the coolest.
Is that --
Is that where you get
your drive? Is that --
-From my mom?
-Yeah.
-Where do you think?
-I think I get my --
like, my personality
from my mom, a little bit.
And you know, both my mom
and dad worked really hard.
-Yeah.
-So I definitely --
-I don't know anyone
that works as hard as you.
-I know. I don't know
what's wrong with me.
I'm not well.
-No, you are unbelievable.
But I've known you
since "Saturday Night Live,"
but I've seen in every --
-I know.
-Every aspect,
and you're just there
and you're just mentally
in the game and you're like,
"Yeah, cool. What's up?
We'll do that," blah blah.
-What's next? Let's do it!
-"We'll do this. What's next?"
-I go...
-This is fun!
-But like, "Marry Me."
You go, "Great,
I'm in this movie."
That's enough for me.
-I mean, I grew up in the Bronx.
My mom'll tell you,
we grew up in the Bronx.
We really didn't have a lot.
You know,
this is a dream come true.
Everything I do,
every single day,
I feel so incredibly blessed.
I feel so lucky to be doing
what I'm doing.
I always wanted to sing.
I always wanted to dance.
My mother loved musicals,
you know,
she showed me them from
when I was very, very little,
and I just had all these dreams
of like doing that.
And so now I'm doing it.
So why not do it all the time?
I'll do it all the time.
You got it. Everybody knows.
-Yeah, yeah. But I mean...
-You guys -- The Roots want
to play all the time.
-Yeah.
-All they want to do is play.
Every chance you get
to pick up a guitar,
whether you're playing or not,
whether you're at work,
you're doing what you love.
-You just want to do, like...
Just play.
-Yeah. You know that.
-I know, but you also did
the soundtrack to this.
-I did.
-You and Maluma are all over --
this is all you.
And this is out now.
The movie comes out next week.
-Yes! Look at it!
Yay!
-Ah, there you go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It never gets old for me.
Yes, this was actually
the first time
since I did the movie "Selena"
where I actually got to --
I didn't sing
in the movie "Selena."
That was Selena's voice.
-Yeah.
-So this is the first time
I got to, like, sing,
make an album for a film.
It is like joining
my two worlds together.
I also got to play a character
who was, you know,
a lot like myself.
You know,
she's in the spotlight,
personal life, public life,
trying to make it all work.
You know,
failing miserably at times.
You know what I mean?
Doing all the things.
But it's a really,
really great kind of look
behind the behind the scenes.
-Yeah, I remember the last time
you were here with Maluma.
-Yes.
-You actually had a scene
in the movie
where you're supposed
to be at a concert.
You guys are doing your famous
duet in character.
-Yeah.
-And instead of re-creating
a fake concert
on a movie set somewhere,
you crashed Maluma's --
-Oh, I did. We did.
-...Maluma's concert.
-Yes, he was having like two
nights at Madison Square Garden.
And of course,
the producer in me is like,
"We can take advantage of that."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, yeah.
It's like, yeah.
Alright, he's already got --
-We have a scene, a big scene
in an arena.
Why don't we do it
at your concert?
And he was like, "Okay..."
-Yeah.
-How'd that feel?
People must have went bonkers --
-It was amazing.
-...when you walked out.
-It was amazing, yeah.
I came up out of the floor
dressed like the character
in the movie,
and this scene is in the movie.
And they just didn't expect me
to come out at his concert.
I've never been out
at one of his concerts.
And the crowd went wild,
and we got it all on film
and we sang together.
And it was -- it was awesome.
-And I will say the whole --
you're on the whole soundtrack,
is you and Maluma.
I mean, this thing is --
it's awesome.
-Yeah, it's not like
a Jennifer Lopez J.Lo album
or even a Maluma album.
It's a Kat and Bastian album.
These are songs that I really
picked for the characters
and that really kind of like
further along the story,
just like any good musical.
-Yeah.
-And it really tells
the love story,
the journey of, you know,
kind of finding your true love.
-We're here with Jennifer Lopez!
Her new movie "Marry Me"
is in theaters February 11th.
And I should mention that I have
a cameo in this movie.
-You do have a cameo.
-We're in a movie together.
-Two cameos.
-I know. I had two cam--
Pretty important scenes.
-Really important scenes.
Actually, one of the scenes
was really important.
It was very emotional.
Because it's one
of those moments
where, like,
people don't get to see
where I kind of had to, like,
let down my guard, too,
where she suffers this terrible
kind of public humiliation
and is on her way home.
And like the night talk show
hosts do, they're roasting her.
And she's crying on the floor
in a puddle.
You know what I mean?
And it's just, like,
one of those moments
that people don't
really think about.
You know, you don't think,
"Oh, God.
Maybe they're laughing at home.
Maybe they can take a joke."
And sometimes it just --
-It just hurts.
-It just hurts, yeah.
And this was the first time,
like, I got to, like, do that.
Because, you know,
we're in show business.
We like to
put our best foot forward.
We're out here. You don't need
to know about our nonsense.
You just sing the song,
do the dance.
We entertain.
We have a good time.
But there's a human being there,
and I think this movie
kind of gets into that.
And you are the talk show host
who's roasting me.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that I got permission
to roast your character, yeah.
But I do think you are perfect
for that
'cause you get to see
all the stuff.
And it's such public stuff.
Everything you do is so public,
'cause you're that famous.
-Yes.
-So, you're having a concert.
You have a very public breakup.
-Yeah.
-And someone, being Owen Wilson,
is in the crowd
and has a sign up.
-Who is so good in this movie!
Oh, my God, you will love him
in this movie.
-He knows how to do it, right?
He knows how to do it.
-He just grounds
the whole thing.
He's just so amazing.
He just has
so much heart and soul.
We're so different.
And we're supposed to be.
We're supposed to be.
-Opposites attract.
-Yes, yes.
-Well, basically,
you're just fed up,
and someone's holding a sign up
at a concert, like you do.
And his says, "Marry me,"
and you go, "Okay."
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like, wait,
what just happened?
-Nothing else is working out.
How about this?
-"Okay, I'm gonna marry you."
-Let's do it.
-"You want to get married?
Let's just do it."
And he's like, "What?"
-Yeah, and it turns into
a whole frenzy with social media
and everything that happens,
and it gets out.
-It's a great idea.
-Yeah. It's fun.
-Do you have any memorable signs
that you see
when you have your concerts?
-So many.
-Yeah.
I mean, I think when I first --
I went on tour pretty late
in my career.
I didn't go
until I was in my 40s
and I had kids
and everything like that.
And so I hadn't tour for like --
I don't know how many.
12 years I had been
recording music,
and I had never done
a proper world tour.
I'd done shows, of course,
here and there always.
But I remember this woman
holding up this sign
and saying, "I've been
waiting 14 years."
Oh, my God,
it's gonna make me cry.
She said -- She said,
"I've been waiting for 14 years
to tell you that you helped me
be the woman that I am today."
I was like, "Oh, my God."
-That's cool, right?
That's powerful.
Because I had never toured --
It was so sweet.
It was just like
you don't realize,
like, your music
is touching people.
You just think you're just
doing this thing.
We do this thing,
and you don't realize that
until you, like, tour the world
and people come up to you,
and I would do
the meet and greets,
and they would, you know,
tell me, like --
show me tattoos of my name
on their back.
And so I'm like,
"What is happening here?"
And it was just amazing
to see it.
So that was
a very memorable sign.
I always think about that.
-I'm so happy you're here.
Congrats on the film.
You look great, as always.
Come on.
You're always rocking it.
-I'm trying to be like you, bro.
-No. Come on, buddy.
Hey. Happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday.
-Thank you, bro.
-Come on, buddy.
If I know Maluma,
I know you probably just spent
a nice quiet birthday
at home, right, just chill.
-It was pretty relaxed.
-Yeah.
I have a video of you
at your birthday.
Take a look at this.
-Let me see.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay.
Yeah. There you go. That's --
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] Uh...
Last time,
we talked about your tour,
and you talked about
you're going to go
back to your hometown...
-Yes, sir.
-...in Colombia and perform.
-Yeah, have the biggest
concert of my career.
It's going to be on April 30th,
in the stadium in Medellín,
representing.
Bro, I'm so happy.
For the first time.
-Medellín.
-Yeah, for the first time,
I'm going to perform
in my hometown.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-After ten years.
-How does it feel?
How does it feel?
-I'm nervous, to be honest.
-Yeah.
-You know,
because it's not the same.
Of course, I'm very blessed --
-You don't want to mess up.
-Yeah, of course,
I'm very blessed
that I've been touring
around the world,
but nothing more important
than your hometown, bro.
So, I'm going to get there,
and I have to kill it.
-You're doing it
in the country's
biggest soccer stadium.
-Yes, sir.
-Which is bigger than --
We can't even imagine it
really here.
-Yeah, it's going to be like
45,000 people.
-Wow.
-So, yeah,
that's why I'm nervous.
-I was talking to you. I go,
"That's big. You're playing
this soccer stadium."
And you go,
"Yeah, I always dreamt
of being in that stadium."
I go, "Oh, that's awesome."
But not as Maluma,
not as a singer.
-Yeah, you're right, bro.
-You played soccer.
-I wanted to be a professional
soccer player.
-Can you still play?
-Yeah.
-You can?
-You? You play soccer or not?
-No. I get exhausted
watching soccer.
-Really?
-It's exhausting.
-I love playing soccer.
I still do it. I still do it.
-I mean, we have a --
I have a ball here.
-No way.
-Could you --
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Could you show me a trick
or something?
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-I'm feeling the pressure.
-Yeah, just pretend this
is the concert.
-The stadium.
-This is the stadium.
Everyone's -- Yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Okay.
♪♪
-Come on, bud. Come on, man.
Yeah, that's what I'm talk--
Yeah! Come on, bud!
Let's go, man.
What in the what?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Yeah, I didn't wear a cup.
I didn't wear a cup.
That's Maluma right there.
Come on.
You know how to do it, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's why I'm singing now.
-Yeah.
You just became, also,
the first recording artist
to design your own bottle
for Hennessy.
-Yeah.
-And this is a thing --
We're going to debut it
right now.
-Yeah, bro, yeah, please.
-No one's ever seen this.
-Please, please, please.
I want them to see it.
I want them to see it, please.
♪ Ba-da-ba-ba ♪
-♪ Da-da-da-da ♪
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Look at it. Look at that, bud!
-Yeah, bro.
-How cool is that, man?
-You like it?
-I love it!
Dude, for being 28 years old
and you get to do this
and play stadiums, look
at what you're doing, buddy.
-Well, because
I really love Hennessy...
That's why I designed it.
-Yeah. Yeah. Me too.
I don't get to design
my own bottle. Yeah.
This looks gorgeous, bud.
-Thank you, bro.
-What goes into this?
I mean, do you look
at different things
and you make a choice and
you go, "I don't like that"?
-Yeah, remember
that I was doing
the "Papi Juancho" tour
here in the States.
So, I was using
a lot of these colors
and also trying to put
my Latin culture
and also
my Colombian culture.
I'm from Medellín, Colombia,
so I wanted just to
bring everything, what I am.
And I feel proud
to be Latin, bro,
so I put everything
in this bottle.
You can -- You can see it.
I feel proud, man, you know.
-Good for you, buddy.
I'm proud.
-Thank you, man.
-I'm proud of you, bud.
Also, I think, you know --
Not only are we besties,
but also --
-What else?
-We are also co-stars
in a movie.
-Of course, bro.
-I make a cameo
in the movie "Marry Me."
-Yes, sir.
And you killed it.
-Yeah.
-I remember.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was hard for you, no?
-It was really tough.
I played myself.
I was like, "Oh, what am I going
to be like in this movie?"
But look at you, though.
You do a voice in "Encanto,"
the biggest movie
in the world right now.
-Yeah.
-Crushing right now.
-Yeah, bro.
That movie is nice because
they're telling the true story
about Colombia.
Beautiful, beautiful things are
told in the movie "Encanto."
Because I don't want people
to think
that Colombia is Pablo Escobar
anymore and all violence.
See "Encanto," man.
It's beautiful.
-That's right.
It is beautiful.
-So I feel great to be
part of the movie, too.
You know?
-That's awesome.
Let's talk about "Marry Me."
Because I'm predicting,
right now,
this is going to start
a new renaissance
of romantic comedies, because
it's so well done, buddy.
And you and Jennifer
have chemistry.
I remember we were talking
when we shot the film here.
We shot a scene here.
And then we went to the Garden
the night before maybe?
-Yeah. The night before.
And then next day we came here.
Yeah, I remember.
-Yeah.
And you shot a scene
from Madison Square Garden.
-Yeah, man.
-How was that?
-It was nice. [ Laughs ]
-Tell the truth.
-No, no, no.
-The truth -- You want me
to tell the truth?
Well, I had fun,
I mean, it was nice.
I was performing with Jennifer.
She came like a queen,
and I just wanted to hug her,
but we had a teleprompter
because I didn't know
the lyrics of the song.
Yeah, right.
And then I started singing,
and I forgot the lyrics.
And I saw the teleprompter,
and the teleprompter went off.
[ Laughter ]
So, it was -- it was here
at the Madison Square Garden,
one of the most important
concerts of my career.
But, yeah -- But Jennifer,
she held me, man.
-She's a pro, right?
-Yeah, yeah, she got my back.
So, at the end of the day,
like, no one realized
that I didn't know the lyrics.
-It's a beautiful song, though.
It's an awesome song.
And you're actually coming back
here to perform it on Friday.
-Yeah. Yeah, on Friday,
we're going to be here.
-"Marry Me."
-I'm going to move
to the studio.
-Just live here. I'll give you
the keys to my apartment.
You can just crash tonight.
Yeah.